deux bateaux pneumatiques rempli à
craquer de passagers secourus au large
de la libye par les gardes-côtes
italiens
218 migrants clandestins de plus dont
six femmes enceintes
le flot de boat people ne tarit pas
malgré les risques
malgré les morts les autorités de malte
ont organisé des funérailles pour les
vingt-quatre corps repêchés après le
naufrage de la fin de semaine tous
anonymes comme les 800 victimes de la
catastrophe
à bruxelles les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des 28 pays de l'union
européenne ont tenu une minute de
silence en leur mémoire
avant d'essayer de trouver ensemble dans
l'urgence une solution au problème
les attentes sont grandes les
populations européennes
ému par l'ampleur du drame ont du mal à
accepter une méditerranée transformer en
charnier et les ong de défense des
droits de l'homme ont bien l'intention
de maintenir la pression
l'union européenne au moins à minima de
toute urgence doit à la fois mettre en
place une opération sauvetage de grande
envergure là où se déroulent les
naufrages et en même temps ouvrir des
voies d'accès sécurisé pour les réfugiés
pour bernard kouchner l'ancien ministre
français des affaires étrangères
l'europe doit agir et vite
c'est une question de vie ou de mort il
faut c'est une manoeuvre d'urgence
envoyer des bateaux de sauvetage
c'est à dire une flottille de sauvetage
une sauf une flottille comment dirais-je
deux humanitaires venues de l'europe 28
p 28 bateaux via une cheminée leinen tu
as finale les 28 ont décidé de tripler
le budget de l'opération de surveillance
des frontières
la france et l'allemagne environ chacune
deux navires et des avions
la grande-bretagne trois bâtiments et
des hélicoptères
l'europe souhaite aussi se donner les
moyens de capturer et de détruire les
bateaux utilisés par les trafiquants
traiter plus rapidement aussi les
dossiers des demandeurs d'asile pour
accueillir plus vite ce qui en droit au
statut de réfugié mais aussi renvoyer
plus vite chez eux ceux qui n'y ont pas
droit
les leaders européens marchent sur des
oeufs
embarrassée par un dilemme la nécessité
de sauver des vies de ne pas paraître
insensible face au drame tout en évitant
d'encourager la venue des migrants la
question de l'immigration ici reste un
sujet très sensible
les dirigeants européens sont loin de
l'ignorer ici jean françois bélanger
radio canada mais ces mesures hésitant
seront elles suffisantes pour répondre à
cet immense flot de réfugiés qui se
massent sur les côtes méditerranéennes
en espérant qu'un bateau les embarquent
pour l'europe
plusieurs d'entre eux sont des syriens
qui partent de la turquie le pays a
accueilli près d'un million et demi de
réfugiés syriens depuis le début de la
guerre civile
il y a quatre ans je joins notre
correspondante marie ève bédard qui est
à merci ndongue dans le sud de la
turquie
marie-eve vous trouvez à peu près à 300
kilomètres des frontières syrienne donc
c'est un point de convergence pour
l'immigrant du tout un peu qui ils sont
ce sont des syriens qui ont fui la
guerre qui fait rage en syrie depuis un
peu plus de quatre ans maintenant et qui
continuent d'arriver céline les gens qui
se regroupent
ici à mercy ne le font surtout justement
à cause de cette proximité à la mer ils
sont en attente d'un passage vers
l'europe espère t-il
ils ont fui les villes d'alep d'abord
mais maintenant de plus en plus ils
libres au fur et à mesure que le conflit
se déplacent les fronts chauds en syrie
il quitte plusieurs des gens qui en a
parlé aujourd'hui viennent du camp
palestinien de yarmouk et en banlieue de
damas cinq ans qui a été pris d'assaut
par le groupe hermitage islamique il ya
quelques semaines maintenant
alors c'est des gens qui n'ont plus
nulle part où aller chez eux en syrie
vient ici en turquie où on les accueille
de façon assez généreuse mais quand même
n'ont pas envie de faire leur vie ici
tout ce dont il rêve c'est de pouvoir
rebâtir une vie en sécurité en europe
alors on comprend qu'il se retrouve aux
mains de passeurs
vous avez vu parler à des gens
aujourd'hui comment est ce que ça
fonctionne qu est ce qu ils doivent
affronter pour pouvoir partir d'abord
des coûts exorbitants pour des gens qui
ont tout laissé derrière des milliers
des milliers de dollars ça varie selon
certains groupes de passants plusieurs
des groupes qui opèrent ici à merci son
syrien ce sont des syriens qui servent
d'intermédiaires ce sont des syriens
aussi qui sert de passeur qui organise
les bateaux qui sont au large dans les
eaux internationales on ne les voit pas
du bord mais on peut acheminer les gens
comme ça qui ont payé leur passage pour
ces bateaux à partir des plus petits
ports ici à merci alors ils ont payé 6
et 1000 dollars ils sont en attente et
plusieurs hôtels dans la ville qui sont
pris d'assaut un peu par ces groupes de
patients on installe les gens là en
attendant de leur donner le feu vert
quand leur bateau est prêt qu'il peut se
lancer en mer ce sont des gens avec qui
attendent très longtemps qui souvent
doivent tenter l'expérience
une deux trois fois plusieurs nous a
raconté avoir tout perdu avec la plaine
première tentative parce qu'on les a
floués les passeurs sont disparus avec
leur argent d'autres ont été interceptés
par les autorités turques qui quand même
tente de garder un contrôle mais en même
temps les passeurs avec qui on a parlé
nous disent qu'ils sont de connivence
avec certains policiers turcs à qui il
fait des pots-de-vin pour pouvoir faire
monter les gens partir de petites
embarcations pour atteindre les plus
gros bateaux qui les attendent au large
alors si toute une industrie comme ceux
qui fleurissent ici qui ne semble pas
non plus en
sur le point de s'essouffler malgré
contente d'appliquer de plus en plus de
restrictions très bien marie-eve même
merci beaucoup on va suivre au cours des
prochains jours vos reportages qui vont
mettre un visage je dirais sur ce drame
là qu'on voit depuis plusieurs jours sur
nos écrans merci beaucoup marie-eve nous
emplit